ein gigant nimmt form an das größte
jemals in deutschland gebaute
kreuzfahrtschiff 337 meter lang 63 meter
hoch mit platz für 6600 passagiere
[Musik]
die brüder reinhard und rainer sind
schiffsbauer auf der werft seit 38
jahren bedienen sie gemeinsam den großen
krank dann musste ich mich schon auf
meinen bruder hundertprozentig verlassen
können dass er auch vernünftig dass wir
irgendwie vielen irgendwie anderen
kleineren fahren
ich sage auch wir nicht hinkommen da war
die herren darum kontakt gehabt bei dem
geburtstag
die brüder haben 1 700 tonnen schweres
bauteil am haken
doch es gibt ein problem
er legt jetzt aus um rund um und da muss
man eventuell geht so wenn ich das ja
dann dann alle probleme
es geht um zentimeter höchste anspannung
für die schiffsbauer
[Musik]
papenburg im emsland die frühschicht
rollt an
annika breed gehört zu den 3500 frauen
und männern die auf der meyer werft
arbeiten
die 34-jährige ist kradfahrerin ihr
vater ihr onkel und drei geschwister
sind ebenfalls auf der werft beschäftigt
der job wurde ihnen quasi in die wiege
gelegt wie das kind ja mit der werff
großmann sich die schiffe über die ems
fahren sind wirklich ganz interessant
und und haben wir 2005 bin ich dazu den
kranführer brücken und bohren sich das
so ein bisschen in der familie der papa
macht da ist auch gemacht das war für
mich immer ganz interessant habe mich
immer sehr interessieren und dann hatte
ich dann die möglichkeit das zu machen
und haben die chance ergriffen
annika arbeitet am rohbau des größten
kreuzfahrtschiffes das in papenburg je
auf kiel gelegt wurde
[Musik]
die aida nova ist an 3 137 meter langer
stahlkoloss ein schwimmendes hochhaus
mit 20 stockwerken
für 6600 passagiere und 1400
crewmitglieder
[Musik]
der respekt ist verliert man nie
forschungsschiff also ich sag mal diese
stadt 500 meter geht ist doch schon
immer wieder wahnsinn was für ausmaße
oder ihr arbeitsplatz heute ist in gut
50 meter
sie bedient den 16 tonnen kran
fragen kassen
[Musik]
jawohl
ein job der präzision und konzentration
verlangt
[Musik]
ja die herausforderung ist natürlich man
muss kopfes zahlen und muss sich dazu
tragen das natürlich eine gewisse
verantwortung
man muss natürlich auch gewisse
feingefühl als frau hat man das sowieso
der bau eines solchen schiffes ist eine
riesige logistische herausforderung im
februar 2018 werden zwei schwimmt teile
ins bett gezogen und miteinander
verschweißt wie lego bausteinen werden
weitere bauteile aufs schiff gesetzt wie
das schiff immer weiter wächst
beobachtet für die reederei
projektleiter sven fahne
[Musik]
also so ein schiffbau ist wirklich wie
ein kind es liegt dass das eigene baby
und man hat schon gehörigen respekt wenn
man nicht nur vorerst und die szene
gesehen hat sondern wirklich live im tor
steht für die nächsten blöcke schneiden
die schiffsbauer einzelne sektionen zu
recht diese sektion starten sie mit
rohrleitungen elektronik und armaturen
aus und dann wird das ganze gedreht
[Musik]
dieses baukastenprinzip ermöglicht ist
kostengünstig und schnell zu bauen
[Musik]
die sieht man sehr schön die bauweise
man kann auf den verschiedenen decks die
als block zusammengeführt wurden kann
man rohrleitungen sehen kabelkanäle die
lüftungskanäle sind wir sind alles schon
einzeln eingebracht worden das sind
alles arbeiten die dann nachher eben
stift nicht mehr gemacht werden müssen
und die auch mal der material aufwendig
sind sven zahlen betritt die brücke das
ist einer der letzten blöcke die noch
ausgerüstet werden
im inneren herrscht kabelsalat rund drei
kilometer leitungen müssen verlegt
werden
man kann sich auch ein bisschen
vorstellen wie das lego prinzip ist ein
schiff stück für stück block für block
entsteht und damit die arbeit an bord in
dieser zeit bewältigt werden kann und
auch in dieser geschwindigkeit
durchgeführt werden kann muss so viel
wie möglich vor ausgerüstet werden
mit dem aufsetzen der brücke ist der
rohbau komplett
[Musik]
800 millionen euro kostet der luxusliner
es ist ein megaprojekt für die
schiffsbauer
[Musik]
mai 2018 die ersten der 2500 kabinen des
ozeanriesen werden komplett
ausgestatteten schiff gebracht
an bord wartet dass ein bauteam die
männer haben 30 minuten zeit um die
einheit zentimeter genau zwischen
bordwand und nachbarkabine zu
positionieren
selbst der fernseher ist schon montiert
alles ist für die urlaubsgäste vorhanden
[Musik]
ein paar stockwerke höher schwebt annika
breed durch die halle
ihre leidenschaft für den beruf hat sie
vom vater
der vater war natürlich so ein bisschen
vorbildfunktion diesen job ganz zu
ergreifen
und es hat mich einfach interessiert
also ich finde das ganz toll so einer
höhe zu setzen man ist immer live mit
dabei wenn man sie kaschiert wachsen
annikas vater rainer und ihr onkel
reinhold heuerten 1980 gemeinsam auf der
werft an
sie sind schiffsbauer durch und durch
untereinander sprechen sie platz man
soll ja ewig sein also ich habe von
meiner frau ist es uns verboten worden
wenn wir nach der arbeit nach hause
kommen und die kinder will mal alle
zuhause oder das nicht nur mal hier und
mal da langsam eine frau und jetzt
schluss die meisten angestellten stammen
aus der region
die werft ist hier der größte
arbeitgeber viele der schiffsbauer
arbeiten seit generationen im
unternehmen
[Musik]
alleine meine familie wir sind hier mit
fünf personen bruder noch mit sechs
personen also nur familie will
es gibt ja mehrere familien die ihre
kinder ja auch haben
aber ich glaube alle vier kinder hat
schon hat schon mit jeder weiß jetzt
erstmal so was bedeutet das für die
region
also man kann ja sehen was hier los ist
also meyer wer und dann kommt jetzt mal
kann zurzeit nichts und ich bin auch
froh dass ich das in ordnung man ist
wichtig ein bisschen wie soll man sagen
muss wie die kohle im ruhrgebiet hat im
emsland der schiffsbau die menschen
geprägt und eine echte gemeinschaft
entstehen lassen
im dock beginnt ein wichtiger
arbeitsschritt die montage der antriebs
gondeln sie sollen unter dem rumpf
befestigt werden
doch das dock ist nur 45 meter breit da
bleibt nicht viel platz zum rangieren
schiffsbauer hermann wessels leitet die
aktion
das ist wirklich millimeterarbeit wir
haben egal sitzen platz ist alles ein
bisschen eng bemessen an der gondel
werden später die propeller blätter
befestigt
[Musik]
die erste runde ist schon montiert jetzt
parallel laufen im drin oben an den dreh
kannst wo bekommen wir eben rang
gefahren haben laufen zurzeit die arbeit
mit dem anziehen
also da sind 72 bolzen drin die werden
im moment angezogen auf drehmoment in
irgend einem schlagring bernhard lübbers
versucht die sicherungsschraube zu lösen
endlich kann die 20 kilo schwere
schraube entfernt haben
die männer wollen den transportwagen
wegziehen
doch dabei streifen sie eine der
propeller gondeln
der schaden sollte leicht auszubessern
seien
heute sehr eng die können nicht nur mit
den folgen
deswegen haben wir hier ganz leichtes
hier zum glück kein größeres problem
denn der zeitplan beim bau des
ozeanriesen ist eng
[Musik]
anfang juli 2018
gut drei monate vor der emsüberführung
das schiff erhält den typischen look
[Musik]
die reederei schickt den zukünftigen
hoteldirektor nicola gülle und soll das
schiff in dienst nehmen
und jetzt ist total aufregend das ist
eigentlich mein erster tag an bord seit
3 endlich mal sehe ich das baby und kann
ich mir genau angucken wird das so
funktioniert wie ich mir vorgenommen
habe
der erste eindruck ist ernüchternd
überall kabel rohre offene verkleidungen
doch der französische hotelchef ist
optimistisch
hier hat die seiten sind hier schon die
ersten unterkünfte und das ist
eigentlich genau das gleiche konzept
alles für unsere passagiere da sind
fabrizierten kabinen die wären da
reingeschrieben dem schiff und dann
dementsprechend angeschlossen
hier sieht man zum beispiel da sie jetzt
eine doppel unterkunft von einer kuh da
drin schlafen zwei mitarbeiter so kurz
wie sieht's aus ist schon fast fertig
soweit so gut wären sie auch schon da
kleinigkeiten besser beseitigen und ihr
wollt aber sonst sieht das gut aus das
ist ein prototyp
das heißt wir kennen die arbeitswege
noch nicht wie erkennung so unterkünfte
noch nicht auch wenn einige sachen
standard bleiben die wege sind andere
draußen bereiten sich die brüder rainer
und reinhold auf einen außergewöhnlichen
schwertransport vor
natürlich auf plattdeutsch verpasst wir
sind zwar brüder oder so aber wir merken
und warum allein wenn es dann wie man
auch mit anderen arbeitskollegen
aufmachen wenn man schwierigkeiten bin
oder so ganz normal
erst jetzt lud ihn aber trotzdem immer
was besonderes auch wenn wir die
hauptmaschine einsetzen oder irgendwie
der effekt der schwede blogger haben und
man die fast unter
das hat besonderes
der job auf dem größten kran der werft
funktioniert im wechsel spielen
rainer ist heute der fahrer sein bruder
der sogenannte antiker er passt am boden
auf und gibt per funk anweisungen wie
das bauteil bewegt werden muss
also ich muss ja jetzt so hoch wie
möglich weil wir über diese arm kräne
weg müssen und dann muss ich mich schon
auf meinen bruder hundertprozentig
verlassen können dass auch vernünftig
kopf nicht dass wir irgendwie gegen den
anderen irgendwie anderen kranen faden
und das ist blindes vertrauen
reinhold ja der idee blog fass ist ja
oben
für rainer heißt es volle konzentration
immerhin hat er 700 tonnen am haken
unter dem bauteil darf sich während der
aktion niemand aufhalten bruder reinhold
und tochter annika passen auf
ich will man mit der apartheid kein
guter tag
da wäre ja und dann moderne bei reiner
lässt den block langsam am 800 millionen
teuren schiff vorbei schweben
doch dann wird klar er wird das riesige
bauteil nicht über die kleineren kräne
hinweg geben können
der weg ist versperrt jetzt wird's eng
weil wir jetzt wegen den arm kern wir
kommen da hinten nicht weit genug gehen
dann müssen die wir müssen jetzt
komplett mit dem blog auflegen und dann
hoffen dass es passt dabei den schwimm-
teilumbau da was sonst haben wir ein
problem erledigt jetzt aus und und und
und da müssen sie eventuell geht so wenn
ich dann das bauteil muss genau in die
lücke massen zwischen der aida nova und
im schwimmteich
also ich vermute dass wir jetzt mit
unserem blog an einem ast von der lg da
sind wir müssen jetzt irgendwas machen
beide dran an den gipfel nicht der mast
ist im weg sondern ein baugerüst das
bemerkten die beiden leider zu spät
ich bin nicht hingucken dabei wir haben
darum schon kontakt gehabt bei dem
gerüst am haus möchte kassenraum
so viel müsste ja wir haben leichte
berührung bei aida gehabt wir können die
hörer und wir können mehr aussehen also
das ist 40 wohl betreibt ist doch eine
verzögerung jetzt während draußen nicht
mehr geht werkeln im innern des schiffes
zahlreiche ausbau firmen rund um den
großen pool werden später bis zu 400
passagiere platz finden
hoteldirektor nicola güllen ist hier mit
projektleiter sven fahle verabredet der
größte fortschritt hier ist natürlich
oben
das foliendach wo schon sämtliche folien
bis auf den letzten beiden hinten
eingesetzt sind
und da sind wir schon wirklich sehr weit
fahren
der hoteldirektor brennt darauf mit
seiner crew die ersten bereiche zu
übernehmen
es ist das dritte schiff dass er in
dienst stellt man kann impulse schön
sehen wir haben die krisen werden hier
kommen noch die letzte buser die
schneckenform ist schon da die bohrungen
sind schon da die lampen rollen sind
auch schon komplett eingebaut das heißt
in die friesen drin sind können wir hier
oben auf das tig drauflegen hat sich das
sind wir voll im plan
ich bin normalerweise sehr ungeduldig
aber das ist jetzt mittlerweile das
dritte schiff wie wir in die
konstellation machen und es hat
funktioniert noch weiterhin sehr gut
also man solange ich meine termine halte
ist er geduldig genau manchmal treten
wir ein wissen aber abend trinken wir
noch mal ein bier zusammen und dann
legen wir die karten auch meinungen
meistens unsere pläne übereinstimmung so
von kriegen wir dann dem entsprechen was
willst du dir so zusammen
bei kranfahrer rainer willms geht es
auch wieder weiter
der 58-jährige kann endlich das 700
tonnen bauteil in die lücke zwischen den
beiden schiffen schieben
seine kollegen haben das gerüst das im
weg war abgebaut
jetzt können die kleineren kräne auf die
andere seite der halle gefahren werden
der weg ist frei für den riesigen blog
[Musik]
der wird jetzt quer durch die halle
befördert und eingepasst
nach gut zwei stunden ist der
schwertransport beendet erleichterung
bei familie williams
aber ist alle zugegangen war nur ein
bisschen gewusst was ein bisschen gehakt
hatte um das haben wir daher nicht
schlimm ist bei grin mag ziemlich eng
geworden aber so schlimm wie dieser blog
hier sind selten welche aber compo es
immer mal was mal nicht so läuft unter
dem schild montiert ein team um
maschinenbauer bernhard lübbers die
propeller blätter die müssen behutsam
mit den antrieb sondern verschraubt
werden die wertvolle bronze legierung
darf nicht beschädigt werden und auch
die beschaffenheit kann man schon dass
wir da sehr sorgfältig umgehen müssen
denn alles ist gefräst alles passgenau
angefertigt worden
die arbeiter müssten vor allem die
gewinde gründlich reinigen und schmieren
die schrauben dürfen sich beim einsetzen
nicht verkannten
für jedes propeller blatt sind passgenau
sechs schrauben im xxl-format
angefertigt worden
[Musik]
bernhard lübbers überwacht das aufsetzen
auf die propellern aber es ist
millimeterarbeit die keinen fehler
verzeiht
vg vorsichtig vor sich mit dem kind
nicht mit dem pence wir sind jetzt fast
mittig drüber und jetzt ist genau das
ein sohn fixierten dass wir dann mit die
über sind und dann langsam über
infizierten das blatt dann nach unten in
den schweizers letztendlich einlassen
[Applaus]
haase hude
[Musik]
bonn
zehn stunden brauchen die männer am ende
für diesen arbeitsschritt dann ist die
antriebseinheit des mega liners komplett
die eigentliche besonderheit des
schiffes befindet sich im maschinenraum
ingenieur stefan schmidt und seine
kollegen setzen beim neuen luxusliner
auf erdgas als treibstoff
bisher fahren kreuzfahrtschiffe mit
giftigem schweröl und gelten deswegen
als umweltsünder
wir sind seit ca 10 jahren an diesem
thema intensiv dran erforschen das
entwickeln das und haben auch seit zehn
jahren versucht reedereien zu finden die
mit uns zusammen das machen
natürlich ist der leidensdruck auf der
anderen seite aufgestiegen durch die
berichterstattung aber auch eben
beruhigt das gewissen was man hat und
diese grüne empfindlichkeit die sich
gebildet hat auch bei reedereien und bei
ihrer kundschaft den besprechen jetzt zu
reagieren
aber grundsätzlich ist es einfach ein
stehen schritt nach vorne technologisch
und ökologisch dazu auch noch das ist
einfach ein riesen vorteil in
kombination dieser beiden aspekte dass
wir jetzt so weit sind dass wir das tun
können
dazu wurden zwei erdgastanks im bauch
des schiffes eingebaut
sie können mit kaltem und dadurch
flüssigem erdgas lng befüllt werden
schiffsdiesel wird nur noch als
notfallreserve und zum anwerfen der
maschinen benötigt die vier motoren
stoßen so gut wie keine schwefeloxide
oder feinstaub partikel aus und sollen
rund 70 prozent weniger stickoxide in
die luft blasen
die großen kreuzfahrtschiffe die sind
halt weltweit unterwegs laufen jeden tag
einen anderen hafen an müssen natürlich
auch planen waren sie tanken müssen aber
müssen auch in der lage seien im
mittelmeer in der karibik in der ostsee
um wo auch immer weltweit eben lng
aufzunehmen und das ist die
herausforderung mit den regularien aber
auch mit den häfen das jetzt zu
entwickeln blickt kommt man sicher aber
es gibt natürlich auch um einen plan b
und plan c
man kann natürlich auch und bunker
schüssen aus diese schiffe bewohnern
aber das ist nicht der plan der plan ist
natürlich von von landseite lng an bord
zu bringen
august 2008 10 der luxusliner verlässt
nach sechs monaten das dorf
die schlepper ziehen den schwimmenden
wolkenkratzer aus der halle und
manövrieren ihn an den kreis
[Musik]
das schiff ist 63 meter hoch das
ausdocken kann das hat nur bis
windstärke 5 stattfinden
sonst könnten das turm hohe schiff aus
der bahn drücken
immer mehr crewmitglieder gehen jetzt an
bord darunter die küchencrew küche küche
küche lautet ihr schlachtruf damit
machen sich die köche und kellner mut
für die nächsten tage
denn unter der führung von chefkoch
alexander massen kai betreten sie ein
schiff auf den kaum ein bereich fertig
ist
da machen die jungs schon war die erste
belebung wunderbar heute soll das erste
mal für die crew gekocht werden
[Applaus]
wunderbar
täglich kommt die bäckerei dazu der
metzger kommt dazu die provision kommt
dazu wir können jetzt also so ganz
langsam hochfahren und jetzt kochen wir
erstmal für unsere führende mitarbeiter
die hier sind und dann gehen wir mehr
ins detail die herausforderung erst eine
der küchen an bord ist abgenommen und
funktioniert von den 17 restaurants ganz
zu schweigen
die befinden sich zwei monate vor der
jungfernfahrt noch im aufbau
dann eine unangenehme überraschung die
lüftung fällt aus
ich habe den plan gerufen die lüftung ja
da kommt die geräte ausgeschaltet oder
der küchenchef holt hilfe während seine
crew im nebel weiter kocht
jetzt sind gerade im moment mal die
lüftung ausgefallen aber der
lüftungstechnik ist schon unterwegs dass
die nutzung wieder angehen
aber das sind so kleinigkeiten die jetzt
in der indienststellung halt passieren
können also sobald die lösung her sagen
geht es dann auch schnell wieder
verzogen
die kommen jetzt noch fertig die sind
auch soweit wir haben jetzt elf uhr
diverse helfen geht raus für die gruppe
befand
als eine der ersten baustellen ist die
kantine komplett fertiggestellt von
jetzt an kann die crew bestehend aus 40
nationalitäten an bord versorgt werden
[Musik]
auf den passagierdecks müssen noch 2500
kabinen abgenommen werden hoteldirektor
nicola göhlen auf kontrollgang wie
sieht's aus hast du die bemerkungen
abgearbeitet
nein es sind noch ein paar übrig wir
warten auf die maler müssen das bild
ausbessern
es ist beschädigt wir müssen auch noch
die schrauben nacharbeiten und einige
silikon stellen ausbessern
da müssen noch schrauben rein ja die
schrauben fehlen hier auch die kabinen
werden mehrfach kontrolliert erst von
der werft dann von der reederei
sogenannten inspektoren team vier
personen die dann dementsprechend
durchlaufen und die machen den
durchschnittlich schaffen durchschnitt
pro truppe 28 kabinen tag
neben luxussuiten und familienzimmern
bietet die reederei zum ersten mal
kabinen für alleinreisende an der
36-jährige hoteldirektor setzt bei allen
kategorien auf ein erprobtes
testverfahren also die kabinen hier sind
eigentlich für unsere besatzung
bezugsfertig also wir werden ihnen
ersten schnitten ihnen den
passagierbereich untergebracht werden
und das ist ganz toll an den job warum
wir so funktionieren weil wir bevor wir
die ersten gäste hier unterbringen
möchten wir alles testen ob alles
funktioniert also ob das nicht wirklich
brennt die abflüsse in die dusche und so
weiter und dadurch sie dir zum beispiel
hier in die betten sind bezugsfertig
weil wir einfach in ein paar stunden
hier geschaffen werden in papenburg
dürfen die gastanks im bauch des
schiffes noch nicht mit erdgas befüllt
werden
die schiffs maschinen werden für den
testbetrieb von land aus von einem
tankwagen mit flüssiggas versorgt
[Musik]
also jetzt gerade in dieser phase testen
wir lng sie können das hier sehen im
moment sind also die flüssiggas flüssig
erdgas tanks hier schon bereitgestellt
angeschlossen mit der aufbereitung
einheit mit unserem schiff verbunden und
die tests finden jetzt gerade statt
sodass also unsere haupt maschinen und
also auch unsere dampfkessel mitgas
beaufschlagt werden in der gasphase
laufen perfekt laufen und letzte
einstellung arbeiten vor unserem staat
und der emsüberführung durchgeführt
werden anfang oktober 2018 die
schleusentore zur ems öffnen sich das
hochwasser ist für die überführung des
riesen schiffes aufgestaut worden
jetzt sollen schlepper tin kho los zum
offenen meer manövrieren
die emsüberführung wird die ganze nacht
dauern für familie williams heißt es
abschied nehmen von ihrem riesenbaby
wie vor haben jetzt das schiff verholt
also das heißt losnummer leinen los wie
wir so sagen
und das hängt jetzt hinten dann
schlepper und vorne ist schlepper und
jetzt wird es so langsam richtung
seeschleuse gezogen und dann geht das
schiff auf die reise
[Musik]
einmal war
mal
[Musik]
ein besonderer moment für die
schiffsbauer
[Musik]
dann kommt der koloss in bewegung
für reinhold wird es eines der letzten
schiffe seien die er auf die reise
schickt bald geht er in rente
das macht einen stolz sein dass man erst
mit arbeiten darf und überhaupt wenn man
sie denn das teil dann aber fertig wird
aus der halle raus gehen und sagen kann
ich hab's nicht gebaut das muss ich
schon sagen es wird mir auch viel
hinterlegen und medien gerät hat das ja
bisschen wehmütige sein land
die schiffsbauer reinhold und rainer
haben ihr leben lang auf der werft
gearbeitet
die brüder hoffen dass die kinder diese
familientradition weiterführen können
die weichen für die zukunft sind
gestellt
die umweltfreundliche technik soll der
werft in papenburg viele neue aufträge
bringen
der erste luxusliner mit erdgas antrieb
der die branche revolutionieren soll
geht auf jungfernfahrt über die ems in
richtung nordsee
[Musik]